what's the math to turn for our polling
station why no young man see we know a
shorter route to your rep to our
democratic polling station you know how
US Democrats like a shortcut like
government spending to prop up the
economy but the more we loved in those
federal programs
you too are Democrats aren't you of
course we are you see the color of our
skin don't you how could we not blindly
vote Democratic I mean that will be
ridiculous
whatever all I know is my polling place
closed in 15 minutes what why that would
be terrible
how are you going to elect tax-and-spend
politicians if you can't vote so not to
vote with all those voter ID laws
Republicans Republican I know I'm just
like you know Republicans here oh I'd be
pissed I'll be royally pissed me too in
fact I would take their hard-fought
principles and that shave it right up
their keisters we seem to be driving in
circles don't worry we're almost there
it appears we've hit somebody we should
get out and help him royally piss now
although it was only this one man's
fault I will be using all of your tax
dollars to get healthy thanks to the
affordable healthcare act I know it
doesn't seem fair but that's supposedly
the law of the land out there you don't
look that hurt
why are wearing those same leather
jackets and those dad jeans just folks
black Republican mother
you